I saw the story and it just it gave me a
chuckle someone in Las Vegas has been
going around and putting miniature
cowboy hats on pigeons did you hear
about this yeah check that out
miniature cowboy hats I'm hit James I'm
not making something is absolutely true
oh that's funny who's doing that okay no
idea no idea who's doing it but that got
us here at the show thinking what are
some other silly hats you can put on a
pigeon well well well my plan worked you
fell for it Conan I knew your dumb show
couldn't resist a stupid news story like
this so I went around Las Vegas and put
tiny cowboy hats on pigeons knowing it
would make the news and you took the
bait hook line stinker why did you do
all this
revenge revenge I don't even know who
you are
oh you don't remember me New York
August 1998 I was 13 and Late Night with
Conan O'Brien's biggest fan after the
show you went outside to sign autographs
for fans I was the kid in the crowd
wearing a conan t-shirt and you didn't
see me I'm sorry it can be really hard
to sign every single autograph in those
situations since you're here do you want
to just get a picture now too late Conan
20 years later I moved to Las Vegas got
a degree in ornithology custom built a
bunch of bird sized cowboy hats and then
one by one put them on pigeons there's
got to be easier ways to get revenge
this was the only way and now i'll live
the rest of my life knowing I've bested
Conan O'Brien
[Laughter]
Coenen look what the hell
[Applause]
thanks a lot pigeon no it's it's Conan
with a great show tonight ladies and
gentlemen and that's the most realistic
sketch we've done in a week we do so
many shows with dead people in the
audience so the question is how long can
the actor hold that we have a terrific
show tonight from Breaking Bad and the
new series the mandalorian Giancarlo
[Applause]